taking a leap at nearly 300 meters above
the ground
this child and seven others spent hours
dangling between two mountains in a
damaged cable car
Pakistan's Special Forces eventually
lifting some of those stranded in the
cart hanging by only one cable to safety
but it was an operation Complicated by
strong winds in the valley with the
forces generated by the rotor Blades of
a helicopter posing a danger to the
unstable cot
a stranded 20 year old using what little
battery he had on his cell phone made an
appeal to a local media channel as they
hung in the air
[Applause]
I don't know how to
how to more it is it should Rescue all
of us as soon as possible
[Music]
Darkness fell
Engineers were called in to assist in
the rescue operation from the ground
right now we are installing another
cable so that through another makeshift
trolley we can make an access to the
ones who are already trapped there and
get them out
authorities explained they initially had
contact with one of the stranded people
who has since been rescued one of the
guys uh in the in the trolley he has got
a phone but uh so far as by now uh what
can I understand is that his battery has
run out and uh the communication is no
more with the guy who was inside the
trolley before this
despite the challenging terrain Rescuers
work throughout the night to bring
everyone to safety
Michael Al Jazeera right
now